Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Then let's take this one.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Fine, let's take this one.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So humble, haha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We're still looking.
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought taro.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac.
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you guys buy konjac?
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: I don't think so.
Katrina:  没有那就够了
Katrina: No, that's enough.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Okay, then I'll take the tofu.
Jake:拍个照
Jake: Take a picture.
Katrina:  火锅调料要买蒜吗
Katrina: Do we need to buy garlic for the hot pot seasoning?
Alice: 哦蒜买了
Alice: Oh, we bought garlic.
Alice: 哦蒜有这个
Alice: Oh, we have this garlic.
Jake:拍个照吧
Jake: Take a picture.
Alice:有这种蒜
Alice: We have this kind of garlic.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就这么草率
Katrina: Hahaha, that's so hasty.
Jake: 再来
Jake: Let's do it again.
Shure:  我们少个人
Shure: We're missing someone.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is he?
Alice:他去放豆腐了
Alice: He went to put away the tofu.
Jake:好等他回来
Jake: Okay, let's wait for him to come back.
Alice:板栗
Alice: Chestnuts.
Lucia: 哎我没有见过这种板栗
Lucia: Oh, I've never seen these kinds of chestnuts.
Shure:  哎萝卜胡萝卜咸萝卜嫩芽子
Shure: Hey, radish, carrot, salted radish, tender sprouts.
Shure:  香椿好韭菜嘞
Shure: Chinese toon, and chives.
Lucia: 观察一下观察一下
Lucia: Observe, observe.
Shure:  变异性了
Shure: It's mutated.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Alice:这还卧了个蛋呢
Alice: There's even an egg here.
Jake: 咱重建一下
Jake: Let's rebuild it.
Jake: 让他重建一下
Jake: Let him rebuild it.
Shure:  青椒哎
Shure: Green pepper, hey.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Alice: 这还是个公的哈哈哈
Alice: This one's male, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Tasha: 这家店没有了
Tasha: This shop is gone.
Alice: 荔浦鱼头
Alice: Lipu fish head.
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This shop is gone.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: Another shop has it.
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: They said it's very close.
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did they say?
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: The other shop is very close.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can they transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found some plastic wrap.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: They can't transfer it.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Take a picture, take a picture, take a picture.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he joining?
Jake: 对和
Jake: Yes, with him.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is it real?
Alice: 假的
Alice: Fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come on, let's take a picture.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:好放回去
Jake: Okay, put it back.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why are we taking a photo with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的
Lucia: This is handy.
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because I saw it.
Alice:下蛋公鸡
Alice: A rooster laying eggs.
Jake:: 公鸡下蛋
Shure:  下蛋公鸡
Shure: A rooster laying eggs.
Shure: 公鸡下蛋公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: Rooster laying eggs, the fighter jet among roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appears.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Alright, everyone's expression is equally stiff.
Katrina:  这好像是个动图吧 是动图吗
Katrina: This seems to be a GIF, right? Is it a GIF?
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Compared to the public.
Shure:  我跟你讲我们原来那个
Shure: Let me tell you, back in the day...
Katrina: 是动图
Katrina: It's a GIF.
Shure:  我们办公室拍照
Shure: We took photos in the office...
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And one of us used to be an idol, you know?
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的你知道吗
Shure: It felt like he was on a different level than us, you know?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: His expression management and style, I mean...
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, go listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: No sound effect, he was mimicking it.
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone for a second.
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Tongue click?
Tasha: 然后我们去买保鲜膜和蛋挞皮吧
Tasha: Then let's go buy some cling film and tart shells.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I can't do it.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: And some mint.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: Might not be able to find it.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And that's it.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Maybe milk powder too.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Take another photo and manage it.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can you manage it?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: Can't manage it.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Manage it, okay.
Shure:  怎么管理一下
Shure: How to manage it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Shure: Just make it look more like a normal human.
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Forbid it, forbid it for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's tough, that's tough.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: Let's do another 10 seconds.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't last 10 seconds in there.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's wait a bit.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effect.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Look at everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: Expression management results?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: It's okay, no big deal.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Dead silence.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Dead silence.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's fine.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina:  还缺啥吗
Katrina: Are we missing anything?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜你们买一下
Tasha: We're still missing cling wrap, can you guys get it?
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: We got it, we got cling wrap.
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: What else?
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Got it.
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: We got cling wrap.
Tasha: 还有什么蛋挞皮
Tasha: What about tart shells?
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Taro from Lipu.
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro.
Alice:没了
Alice: Nothing else.
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake's getting stressed.
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did we get mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: We didn't get mint.
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: There's no mint.
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: Maybe there's no mint.
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: All these are cheap, right?
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: You know the saying "tiny grains build up a tower"?
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: Or "the last straw that breaks the camel's back"?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shells.
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last tart shell.
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last tart shell.
Alice: 实在没有薄荷要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: If there's really no mint, let's go downstairs and pick some leaves.
Shure:  咱们去那个那什么
Shure: Let's go to that place and buy a new pot.
Shure:  买一盆新的就行
Shure: Just buy a new one.
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some flowers we have and use them for decoration.
Jake: 能带我起来吗
Jake: Can you help me get up?
Lucia: 啊小心小心
Lucia: Ah, be careful, be careful.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia: 这些非工作人员请勿触碰
Lucia: Non-staff members, please don't touch.
Lucia: 小心危险
Lucia: Be careful, it's dangerous.
Jake:我也不碰了
Jake: I won't touch it either.
Katrina: 老北京豆汁
Katrina: Traditional Beijing soybean milk.
Lucia: 但实话说我也挺好奇
Lucia: But honestly, I'm quite curious.
Lucia: 他们上面那个Logic chain是干嘛用的
Lucia: What's that logic chain they have on top used for?
Lucia: 我们诶这个好可爱
Lucia: Wow, this is so cute.
Lucia: 啊扫描一下
Lucia: Ah, scan it.
Jake: 从上往下拍会好吗
Jake: Will it be better to take it from the top down?
Lucia: 呃会好一点
Lucia: Uh, it'll be a bit better.
Lucia: 一般来说这个角度会显得人脸瘦一点
Lucia: Generally speaking, this angle makes the face look slimmer.
Jake:那就让他从上往下拍
Jake: Then let's have them shoot from top down.
Jake: 齐吧人不齐好的呀
Jake: Are we all here? Good.
Jake:那个
Jake: Um.
Jake:哎呦我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my god, hahaha.
Lucia: 那就等10秒
Lucia: Then let's wait 10 seconds.
Jake: 可以有点糊啊
Jake: It's a bit blurry.
Jake:这聚焦怎么聚哪去了
Jake: Where did the focus go?
Lucia: 好像有那么一点点糊
Lucia: It seems a bit blurry.
Lucia: 但你是清楚的
Lucia: But you're clear.
Jake: 聚我头上去了
Jake: The focus is on my head.
Jake: 我这个目标太大
Jake: I'm too big a target.
Lucia: 没事说明他这个抓住重点
Lucia: It's fine, it means it focused on the main point.
Alice:想拍老板
Alice: It wants to capture the boss.
Jake: 现在对了现在对了好
Jake: Now it's right, now it's right, good.
Lucia: 啊可以或者
Lucia: Ah, maybe or...
Katrina: 又来哈哈哈
Katrina: Here we go again, hahaha.
Lucia: 又没聚住吗
Lucia: Is it out of focus again?
Shure: 5秒就行
Shure: 5 seconds is enough.
Jake:直接来吧
Jake: Let's just do it.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Alice:那种的
Alice: That kind.
Katrina:  他俩找蛋挞皮去了吗
Katrina: Did they go to find tart crusts?
Jake: 好要压死我了
Jake: Okay, they're going to crush me.
Jake: 哪哪
Jake: Where, where?
Jake:蛋挞皮
Jake: Tart crusts.
Jake: 哦在那
Jake: Oh, over there.
Lucia: 啊哪里
Lucia: Ah, where?
Katrina:  什么呀薄荷
Katrina: What is this, mint?
Tasha: 没有问过服务台了
Tasha: Didn't ask the service counter.
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and that taro thing.
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And there's no tart crust either.
Alice: 对别的都可以
Alice: Yeah, everything else is fine.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: I just saw a bag go by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: That's exactly it.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it that hard to take a few steps?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: Should we add some light cream?
Lucia: 你说 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: You know, to give everyone a high-tech illusion.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: As for the tart crust...
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: Actually, this thing looks like a microphone from the steampunk era.
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Yeah, the shiny kind.
Tasha: 但是我想要
Tasha: But I want it.
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, Okun?
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, boutique.
Jake:草履虫
Jake: Paramecium.
Jake: 嗯大细菌
Jake: Um, big bacteria.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli.
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: It's like those little sugar sprinkles on birthday cakes, the strawberry ones.
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Ah, this donut.
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite.
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man behind.
Jake:这个猫头鹰啊
Jake: This owl, huh?
Jake:姜饼人人那
Jake: Gingerbread man over there.
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's up with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Want Want milk.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Want Want milk.
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: Over in the milk section, I think.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 你是因为镜头在录所以保出节目效果
Tasha: You're trying to create some show effect because the camera is recording.
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: It's like Sam's Club, I think.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: No, then why did you hit me?
Jake:为了把你丢这个钻石丢在我的身上啊
Jake: So you threw this diamond at me, huh?
Jake:为了把就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: You hit me and then lost the diamond.
Tasha: 有汉堡胚 要不要做汉堡
Tasha: We have burger buns. Want to make burgers?
Jake:可以做真的可以做哎
Jake: Sure, we can really make them!
Tasha: 要做汉堡芝士芝士
Tasha: Let's make burgers with cheese!
芝士皮 生菜和番茄洋葱就行了
Tasha: Cheese slices, lettuce, tomato, and onions, that's all we need.
Jake:听起来也还行吧
Jake: Sounds good, right?
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:可以做
Jake: We can do it.
Jake:那就做呗
Jake: Let's do it then.
Tasha: 你想吃吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat it?
Jake: 好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 你不想吃算了 KFC给你买得了
Tasha: If you don't want it, forget it. I'll get you KFC instead.
Jake: 好啊好啊在哪里啊
Jake: Sure, sure. Where is it?
Jake: 结账去了应该
Jake: Probably at the checkout.
Jake: 收银区去了收银区见啊
Jake: At the cash register. See you there.
Tasha: 你想要我帮你打个折吗
Tasha: Do you want me to get you a discount?
Jake: 怎么折啊
Jake: How?
Tasha: 怎么折
Tasha: How?
Jake: 你有盒马的折吗
Jake: Do you have a Hema discount?
Tasha: 我 借的会员
Tasha: I borrowed a membership.
Jake:还是什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 借的会员
Jake: Borrowed membership?
Tasha: 那肯定要借嘛
Tasha: Of course, I had to borrow it.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Yes?
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn.
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: I'm done scanning.
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you have to scan the membership code first.
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, I don't have it.
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: Isn't a regular membership enough?
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, you have to...
Katrina: 找88会员
Katrina: Get an 88 membership.
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: I'll do it.
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does the 88VIP include Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: Get the 88... no, it's an 88 discount for Hema.
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Um, I... wait a second.
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Does Shure have it or...?
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app.
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: Me too, me too, I don't have it either.
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: Yes, I still have a coupon.
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't click on it.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: At Hema, you have to use the app to check out.
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first came back to the country, I went shopping with my dad.
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: And found out you can only check out using the app.
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: So I left without buying anything.
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Haha, so if you want to use two trolleys,
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: how do you put them back?
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西
Lucia: It's because of the stuff we took that day.
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: The stuff we took was fine.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, how about I get one for you?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Alright, you have Alipay, right?
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: Yeah, I have Alipay.
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Then Alipay works too.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay is still available.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have that thing on?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but once you turn off that thing, doesn't that thing stop?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: It's okay to record my home address, right?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They seem to handle it.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yeah, we'll check it later.
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: It's quite stressful.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: Watching all your clips.
Lucia: 交给你了加油
Lucia: It's up to you, good luck.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's okay.
Katrina: 这样也可以啊
Katrina: This way is fine too.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because I think when I look at my phone,
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I will definitely see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or something similar.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: As soon as I open the app, my home address is defaulted.
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: When I opened Taobao to check for material packs today, it was the same.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 辛苦了哈哈
Lucia: Thank you, haha.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we bring another car over?
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it in.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: No, no, it might hang up.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Jake:还有挺好挺好
Jake: Oh, good, good.
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How are we going to take all this stuff?
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: In bags.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: Bags, huh.
Lucia: 有种给自己脑子接口一样的感觉
Lucia: Feels like I'm plugging my brain in.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like charging yourself as an AI robot.
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Charging, yeah, yeah, no power left.
Tasha: 你怎么可以
Tasha: How could you?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm very skilled at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: Nobody's more skilled than me.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: Let me help you.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Thanks a lot.
Jake:我觉得自己这确实有点难
Jake: I think this is actually pretty tough.
Jake:多少拿着点啊
Jake: Hold on to something.
Jake:疼吗
Jake: Does it hurt?
Tasha: 不疼好了吗
Tasha: No, does it look okay?
Jake:好行
Jake: All good.
Jake:好了
Jake: It's done.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:好了好了
Jake: Yeah, all done.
Tasha: 买二赠三
Tasha: Buy two, get three free.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: Okay, it's done.
Jake:好了啊
Jake: It's done?
Jake:可以
Jake: Great.
Lucia: 就跟打针一样
Lucia: Just like getting a shot.
Jake:他妈他妈
Jake: His mom, his mom.
Jake: 好了哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again.
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And there are two more coupons.
Jake: 他是什么每100每500省10块
Jake: What's the deal, save 10 bucks for every 100 or 500?
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, these are my red envelopes, okay?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself.
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh, oh, thank you for donating 10 bucks.
Jake: 这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: So, this is a 10-dollar donation, right?
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: How do I scan with AliPay?
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: This car hasn't been scanned yet.
Lucia: 那边应该都扫过了
Lucia: That side should be all scanned.
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: But these two bags aren't enough, it seems.
Katrina:  行吧再再要一个袋子是吧
Katrina: Alright, should we get another bag?
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗
Tasha: Can it really be paid successfully?
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 SGD.
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 SGD, right.
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: One car for 100 SGD.
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 SGD.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: I spend 100 SGD for each plastic bag.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake, you are so generous.
Lucia:感觉不值 没到一车呢
Lucia: It doesn't seem worth it, it's not even one car.
Lucia: 这边才装了
Lucia: It’s only filled here.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: That might be 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one has been paid.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yes, everything here is paid.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: This one here seems unpaid.
Katrina:  没有放台上
Katrina: It's not put on the counter.
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How do we put this?
Lucia:咋要不 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: How about we move everything here first?
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Let's get another car.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I'll get another car.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Another car.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need, oh OK, got it.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Just move all of this over and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the filled ones in this car.
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: So, it's not paid yet?
Jake:结账要先下载好盒马APP才能结账
Jake: You need to download the Hema app to check out.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Let's pack the bags over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: There's no Hema in Singapore, right?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: Probably not.
Jake: 我探索的也不多
Jake: I haven't explored much.
Katrina:  那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Katrina: What kind of supermarkets are there in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: The kind with natural fibers.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, they have a fire price.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: The government must have given them a lot of subsidies.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called fire price.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: Very cheap, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This wire always makes me feel weird.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Hey, let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: How about we put it behind you?
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Lucia: 有点卷插头
Lucia: The plug is a bit tangled.
Lucia: 给他弄直一点
Lucia: Straighten it out a bit.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like I'm moving it around.
Lucia: 他就快要把我缠起来了
Lucia: And it almost wraps around me.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is a well-tested way of plugging it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Yes, actually, it's best to loop it around the back and stick some tape.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done similar experiments?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: This arrived in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I've been taking it around.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: To watch games and stuff.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I take this thing everywhere in the city.
Lucia: 哦看比赛还可以那
Lucia: Oh, so you can watch games with it?
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: Does it record the whole game?
Jake: 不会不会
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: No, it can't, due to copyright issues.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: It can only scan the entrance ceremony.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: So,
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can it record movies when watching in theaters?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That's not okay either, right?
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: It involves copyright too.
Tasha: 这不就是枪版
Tasha: Isn't that just a bootleg?
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, that's a bootleg.
Lucia: 3D枪版
Lucia: 3D bootleg.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: That's a bootleg.
Lucia:给你秀一个 实景的  坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: I'll show you a real-life experience of sitting in a theater.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I'll take this in and print it out for you.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'm taking this gear into the cinema.
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like my legs are going to break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go grab two more bags.
Jake: 耍赖吗
Jake: Are you cheating?
Jake: 这边有冰块
Jake: There are ice packs here.
Jake: 保鲜冰块
Jake: Fresh-keeping ice packs.
Jake: 保鲜冰块能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat these fresh-keeping ice packs?
Alice: 呃不能吃
Alice: Uh, no, you can't eat them.
Jake: 好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 但是你可以带
Tasha: But you can bring them.
Tasha: 呃也不用吧
Tasha: Uh, no need actually.
Jake: 我们用不着吧
Jake: We don't need them, do we?
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it a bit.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correct the vision.
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: All six of us have the same problem.
Jake: 病友
Jake: We're like patients.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, right.
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yeah, this is the panoramic view.
Tasha: 博主探店的
Tasha: The blogger visiting the store.
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Blogger, blogger.
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yeah, a blogger with six people.
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yeah, seen online, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈妈的 自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Hahaha, damn it, are we opening our own supermarket?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Opening our own Hema.
Lucia: 同时探店这个也做美食
Lucia: While visiting the store, also doing food reviews.
Lucia: 哈哈我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, we have a food expert.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait, don't scan anymore.
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: We can still use the next coupon.
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: We haven't reached 500 yet.
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: No need to reach 500.
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Spend 20, hahaha.
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Okay, last one.
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Just grab a few coupons.
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha, spend 20, spend 20.
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: You first, you first use that $10 off on $500.
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: Reached $500.
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: $49 off and $29 off, hey.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the $49 off first.
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: $29 off fruit coupon.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the $49 off first.
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: Yeah, that's about right.
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: It doesn't matter.
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan so many in a day.
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: There's also a seafood coupon.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Do we have seafood?
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than one SGD.
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood scanned already?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: No, we didn't buy seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One SGD is very important.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One SGD can...
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can it buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: No, it can't, haha.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Does shrimp paste count as seafood?
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, that part was...
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Forget it.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Let's leave it at that.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can one SGD do?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Has this been scanned?
Alice: 1新币能坐公交或许
Alice: One SGD can take the bus, maybe.
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: Can't take the bus, haha.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it costs 1.7.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added another one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  那个但是他是这个吗
Katrina: But is it this one though?
Katrina:  他们那边公交路上
Katrina: On their bus route...
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: It's not.
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, right?
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's two RMB in China too.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's two here as well.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: And two over there as well.
Alice: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Alice: Using Alipay domestically only costs this much.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This can hold a ton of drinks.
小薇 : 扫过了这都是扫过的
Tasha: Scanned already, all these are scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table is scanned.
Tasha: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Tasha: Can this really hold that much weight?
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: Don't press it down, don't press it down.
Tasha: 好了万一托着底抱托着底抱
Tasha: Okay, just support it from the bottom, support it from the bottom.
Tasha: 能扎上吗
Tasha: Can it be tied?
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: I'll tie it, I'll tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this, lift it up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: And then put this here to tie it.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier to tie.
Jake: 哎呦进不去
Jake: Oh no, it won't go in.
Lucia: 这个好重这个袋子
Lucia: This bag is really heavy.
Jake: 分两袋吧
Jake: Let's split it into two bags.
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two cars.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Get another car.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'll go drive.
Alice:你去吧
Alice: Go ahead.
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car is here.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Do you want to take out another bottle of drink?
Katrina:  他没有布袋子吗
Katrina: Doesn't he have a cloth bag?
Katrina:  只有这种袋子
Katrina: Only these kinds of bags?
Tasha: 能不能租个推车回去
Tasha: Can we rent a cart to take back?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 谢谢会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Thanks, isn't it a bit heavy?
Tasha: 你不会在思考这个可行性吧
Tasha: Are you seriously considering the feasibility of this?
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:对 可以吗
Jake: Right. Is it okay?
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No.
Jake: 真的吗问问
Jake: Really? Ask around.
Jake: 哎呦sorry不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, my bad, my bad.
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西
Lucia: These are all things that can't be pressed.
Jake: 这能租推车吗
Jake: Can we rent a cart?
Jake: 那那好吧
Jake: Well, okay then.
Jake: 那上哪租你知道吗
Jake: Do you know where to rent it?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay
Jake: 他这不行
Jake: This won't work
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where's your camera?
Jake: 呃换一个
Jake: Uh, change it
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This one's out of battery
Tasha: 这些先放车里吧
Tasha: Let's put these in the car first
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: The head fell off
Katrina: 来吧放这去
Katrina: Come on, put it here
Lucia: 我们还有袋子吗
Lucia: Do we have any more bags?
Lucia: 没有的话应该也能装下
Lucia: If not, we can still fit it
Lucia: 对要不把这个
Lucia: Yeah, maybe use this
Katrina:  付钱喽
Katrina: Time to pay
Jake: 送的呀
Jake: It's free
Alice:付钱喽
Alice: Time to pay
Jake: 要买
Jake: We have to buy it
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: Do we need to buy kitchen wipes for 9 yuan?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because we're having hotpot, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: 9 yuan seems like a lot
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really still have that much money?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you're really rich
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You believe wrong
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's a bag of green onions here
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this settled?
Lucia: 这是蒜
Lucia: This is garlic
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this green onion?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: This is garlic sprouts
Alice:一样的一样的
Alice: Same thing, same thing
Tasha:无所谓
Tasha: Whatever
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who cares, who brought the green onions?
Lucia: 再买一个吧
Lucia: Let's buy another one
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: Sure, we can buy it
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: Ah no, I think this is green onion
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: This, this is garlic sprouts
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, it's garlic sprouts
Shure:  完全不是一个味
Shure: They taste completely different
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, just use it like green onions.
Shure:  咱俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: We totally have different tastes.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: Different tastes.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic sprouts taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: I just picked it up and suddenly saw.
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What is this thing exactly?
Shure:  另一张另一张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Where is the other bill?
Tasha: 再再买个葱吗
Tasha: Should we buy more green onions?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There's another bill.
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: The first one is done.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who has it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I don't have it.
Shure:  忘忘塞到哪了
Shure: Forgot where it was put.
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: I probably didn't take it.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I should not have taken it.
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I should not have taken it.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe someone took it.
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: Two? Oh my.
Lucia: 哎那怎么又变成两条了
Lucia: Hey, how did it become two?
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were two to begin with.
Lucia: 还有一条
Lucia: There’s another one.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: Should be combined.
Lucia: 本来就两条
Lucia: There were two from the start.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey hey hey, go get the green onions.
Jake: 订一下
Jake: Order it.
Alice:有机葱比较贵
Alice: Organic green onions are more expensive.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: 结过账的东西要看好
Lucia: Watch the things that have already been checked out.
Jake: 去贴门禁
Jake: Go stick the access control.
Shure:  布袋是热啊
Shure: The bag is hot.
Katrina: 绝对不能让任何一个蛋受到伤害
Katrina: Absolutely cannot let any egg get damaged.
Katrina: 封条
Katrina: Seal it.
Jake: 那不多
Jake: Not much.
Shure:   绶带
Shure: Ribbon.
Jake: 呃买二得三
Jake: Uh, buy two get three.
Katrina: 你在英国呆有没有人就是抢
Katrina: Have you ever had anyone just snatch things in the UK?
Katrina:  有没有人就是抢这个
Katrina: Is there anyone grabbing this?
Jake: 总共就两条吧
Jake: There are only two, right?
Lucia: 哦好像有这种事吧但我没有
Lucia: Oh, it seems like that happens, but I haven't.
Lucia: 据说有我们可以讨论这个吗
Lucia: I've heard of it. Can we talk about this?
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Lucia: 涉嫌什么谈论
Lucia: Suspected of talking about what?
Lucia: 谈论那个
Lucia: Talking about that.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说一些不好的话
Lucia: Hahaha, say something bad.
Jake: 没关系就这个翻译给他乱翻译一个
Jake: It's fine, just translate it randomly for him.
Jake: American is the best
Jake: American is the best.
Lucia: 会翻译成这样吗
Lucia: Will it be translated like that?
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How can we take this back?
Katrina:  一人一个
Katrina: One for each person.
Jake: 翻译翻过去就是美国的东西很便宜
Jake: Translate it as American stuff is cheap.
Jake: 大家喜欢买便宜的东西
Jake: Everyone likes to buy cheap things.
Lucia: 大家喜欢花最低的价格买东西
Lucia: People like to buy things at the lowest price.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 经济很好
Jake: The economy is great.
Jake: 让眼镜记一下
Jake: Let the glasses guy note this.
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Tasha: Want me to stick it on for you?
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, hahaha.
Jake: 你就你就
Jake: You can, you can.
Jake: 你就确实可以当
Jake: You can really do it.
Jake: 绶带现在这个长度很好
Jake: The sash length is just right.
Jake: 就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 这车能推到哪啊
Jake: Where can we push this cart?
Shure: 门口
Shure: To the door.
Jake: 门口
Jake: The door.
Jake: 哪个门口外边
Jake: Which door, outside?
Tasha: 肯定也会在网上买的吧
Tasha: Surely they'll buy it online too, right?
Tasha: 车不能推到商场门口吗
Tasha: Can't the cart be pushed to the mall entrance?
Jake: 能租车
Jake: You can rent a car.
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, start the car first.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: Should we buy some coffee or something?
Jake: 现在有点晚了是吧
Jake: It's a bit late now, right?
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Katrina: Are we going straight to eat?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Tasha: What are we going to eat?
Shure:  你们拎着这么多东西
Shure: You guys are carrying so much stuff.
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Alice: Is there any place to put this?
Jake: 确实啊
Jake: Yeah, seriously.
Shure: 肯定得回趟家
Shure: We definitely need to go home first.
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Lucia: It's a bit much to take all this stuff out to eat.
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Tasha: How about we just order takeout?
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Sure, let's go home and order takeout.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We can all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: The thing is, we have frozen items here, right?
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Right, we do have frozen items.
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Yeah, and we also have stuff that needs to be frozen.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen items.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: So everyone take a look and see which items are frozen.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: And which ones are refrigerated.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: For example, like the tripe.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: It needs to be kept at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Yeah, do you need another car?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: It can only go up to here.
Tasha: 他只能到这儿了
Tasha: It can only go up to here.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the journey is up to you.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure:  他现在向你发出回应
Shure: Now he is responding to you.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: So now our fridge is full.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge handle all this?
Katrina:  哈哈哈全喝光
Katrina: Hahaha, drink it all up.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Later.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is quite important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: When you guys are organizing later,
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: it will connect with the supermarket.
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: Some of your actions will be linked.
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For instance, when you put this stuff in the fridge,
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: it can only trace back to where you found it.
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, like Amazon's cashier-less stores.
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: It feels like that.
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yeah, exactly, traceability.
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Yes, it's about traceability, this rechieve
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys going on-chain?
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amos has opened several of those
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: Those supermarkets
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: Where you don't need to check out
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: It knows what you bought
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: And it automatically charges your account
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: Based on the weight
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: Like you put stuff in and it calculates the weight
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Yes, it can be accurate to the milligram
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: And then it automatically deducts the money
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: Just like us
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Then I need to, uh
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: It has lots of cameras
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: It can see what you took
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: It monitors if you took stuff from the shelves
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: Including all kinds of data when you enter and exit
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's a really amazing thing
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But there's a chance it makes mistakes sometimes
Shure:  因为每一个我都这么拿
Shure: Because I take every single one like this
Lucia: 哎那个好像他也能监测的到
Lucia: Hmm, it seems like it can monitor that too
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Haha, but sometimes it does make mistakes
Shure:  我打个雨伞呐
Shure: I'll grab an umbrella
Lucia: 去实验一下
Lucia: Go test it out
Shure:  就是这是他的玻璃
Shure: This is his glass
Jake:玻璃好歹还在人家
Jake: At least the glass is still there
Jake: 好歹还算算法错误
Jake: At least it's a calculation error
Shure:  就是我就爱打伞
Shure: I just love using umbrellas
Shure:  在室内
Shure: Indoors
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 他有可能是商品上面贴条了
Jake: It might have RFID tags on the products
Jake: 贴无线电
Jake: Wireless tags
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He'll arrive in 6 minutes
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start heading down
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: Seems like we're heading up
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: This is going up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧
Katrina: Let's go down
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: So this is how we got up here.
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's what happened.
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: Right when you enter, there's an elevator.
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: Because this place feels like a basement.
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit eerie, not very lively.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You, you carry two by yourself?
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Jake: You, you, you are that strong?
Lucia: 那我再放下一个
Lucia: Then I'll put one down.
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: That's more like it.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:这样比较平衡
Jake: This way it's more balanced.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Tasha: Hahaha, these eggs are really heavy, right?
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Lucia: Haha, these eggs are precious.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure: I'll only take you to the door.
Jake:好 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Alright, did I drop my line?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: Boss is carrying the most stuff.
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you need help putting it on?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Just a moment.
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't move.
Jake: 开始开动
Jake: Let's get started.
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected.
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is that the boss?
Shure:  不是老板吧我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: No, right? We're being led by an AI.
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: Just the ones on my head and in front of me.
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: Those are my receiving devices.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely on them to support me.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Hahaha, for some actions.
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is turning into a horror movie.
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This scallion hit your foot.
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: I'll hold it for you.
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Oh, really? Thanks.
Jake: 很重要这个东西
Jake: This thing is very important.
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Hahaha, critical.
Alice:买了买了
Alice: Bought it, bought it.
Shure:  买了这么大一节葱白
Shure: Bought such a big piece of leek.
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, this is still garlic chives.
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our leeks are in that basket.
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: Bought a combo of leek, ginger, and garlic.
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone carrying a string is kinda cool.
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: When you look at it...
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we walk together like this.
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: Feels like some kind of organization.
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: Later, on my way back, I'll take the subway.
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Should we record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: Sure, record it.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially with these glasses glowing.
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But the subway ride will take almost two hours.
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Subway, subway.
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just get in and get out.
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just go in.
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Go in and then turn it off.
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is you look at your defense.
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Haha, your defense.
Shure:  真的真的好录吗
Shure: Really, really can record it?
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient?
Jake:方便
Jake: Convenient.
Jake: 你问Andy对吧你的老师Andy
Jake: You ask Andy, right? Your teacher Andy.
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: Tell him I'm doing a weird project.
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Yes, ask Andy if he wants to be in the dataset.
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: See if he wants to be researched.
Shure:  安妮好像英国人会对这
Shure: Annie, I think, as a Brit, is more sensitive about this.
Shure:  隐私方面更敏感一些吧
Shure: More sensitive about privacy, right?
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: Here is where we just...
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: The recent one.
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: This was the pathfinder.
Katrina:  这个应该也能出去吧
Katrina: This should be able to go out too, right?
Lucia: 我们为什么不从那里出呢
Lucia: Why don't we go out from there?
Jake: 帮我接个电话
Jake: Answer a call for me.
Jake: 算了我来
Jake: Never mind, I'll do it.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you off here, then I'll leave.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, see you.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Oh, I feel like scratching my head, damn.
Jake: 喂你好Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hello.
Shure:  明天见希望你今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow. Hope you don't miss me tonight.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well!
Jake: 唉好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 呃呃我找找你吧
Jake: Uh, uh, I'll look for you.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll follow the location to find you.
Jake: 你到了对吧
Jake: You've arrived, right?
Jake: 哎哎拜拜拜拜
Jake: Okay, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Alice: 我们这能放下吗
Alice: Can we fit this here?
Lucia: 同想问
Lucia: Was wondering the same.
Alice:可以吧
Alice: Should be okay.
Jake: 好像说在那个地方
Jake: Seems like it's over there.
Jake: 你看你看是在
Jake: Look, look, it's there.
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Yeah, go out this door.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 我们刚刚下车的地
Alice: Where we just got off.
Jake: 那你帮我导个航
Jake: Can you navigate for me?
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Thanks a lot.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Oh, wow.
Lucia: 没有那袋重
Lucia: Not that heavy.
Jake: 谢谢 这个很重要这个很重要这个
Jake: Thanks, this is really important, really important.
Jake: 哎可以谢谢谢谢
Jake: Oh, great, thanks, thanks.
Alice:好了不用走了就在这
Alice: Alright, no need to walk further, just here.
Jake:就在这
Jake: Just here.
Katrina:  他能进来吗
Katrina: Can he come in?
Jake: 他能进来啊
Jake: He can come in.
Jake: 这么厉害
Jake: So impressive.
Jake: 今天挺暖和的
Jake: It's quite warm today.
Jake: 一点也不冷
Jake: Not cold at all.
Katrina:  新加坡一般多少度啊
Katrina: What's the usual temperature in Singapore?
Jake: 呃 23-31每天
Jake: Uh, 23-31 degrees every day.
Katrina:  这么热一年四季都是吗
Katrina: That hot all year round?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day the same.
Tasha: 这么热嗯
Tasha: That hot, huh?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day the same.
Jake: 是挺闷的
Jake: It's quite stuffy.
Jake: 但是现在我适应了我觉得还好
Jake: But now I'm used to it, it's okay.
Jake: 只要中午不出去都还好
Jake: As long as we don't go out at noon, it's fine.
Lucia: 你们是四季如夏吗
Lucia: Is it summer all year round for you guys?
Jake: 对每天都一样
Jake: Yeah, every day is the same.
Jake: 赤道2度北纬2度
Jake: 2 degrees north of the equator.
Lucia: 真的好热
Lucia: It's really hot.
Alice:往那再走一点点
Alice: Move a little bit more over there.
Katrina: 路边是不是应该进不来吧
Katrina: The roadside shouldn't be accessible, right?
Tasha: 他不能进来吗
Tasha: He can't come in?
Jake: 到了吗
Jake: Are we there yet?
Tasha: 让他打电话问他一下吧
Tasha: Let him call and ask.
Jake: 我这个电话我这欠费了
Jake: My phone's out of credit.
Jake: 打不出去
Jake: Can't make calls.
Tasha: 让他进来再调个头
Tasha: Let him come in and then turn around.
Jake: 他是什么色的
Jake: What color is he?
Jake: 他是要我们走过去吧
Jake: Does he want us to walk over?
Alice:我们应该往前走一点点吧
Alice: Should we walk a bit forward?
Jake: 那我们走吧
Jake: Then let's go.
Jake: 走哎
Jake: Come on, let's go.
Jake: 我刚刚拿的是这个吗
Jake: Was I holding this just now?
Alice:是
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 这是地铁吗
Jake: Is this the subway?
Alice: 喂您好
Alice: Hello, hi.
Jake: 最前面这一条
Jake: The very front one.
Jake: 天上这一条
Jake: The one in the sky.
Lucia: 是的那呃
Lucia: Yes, that uh...
Jake: 1号线哎
Jake: Line 1, hey.
Jake: 是1号线吗
Jake: Is it Line 1?
Jake: 奔驰啊是吗呵呵呵
Jake: Mercedes, right? Haha.
Alice: 永和大王门口
Alice: In front of Yonghe King.
Lucia: 永和大王那边吗
Lucia: Over by Yonghe King?
Tasha:嗯嗯OK 门口
Tasha: Uh-huh, okay, at the entrance.
Alice:是是那个吗
Alice: Is it that one?
Alice: 我靠哎呀
Alice: Oh my gosh, oh dear.
Alice:双闪的
Alice: The one with the double flashers.
Alice:看到有双闪
Alice: See the double flashers.
Katrina: 啥颜色
Katrina: What color?
Jake: 啊我看到了
Jake: Oh, I see it.
Jake: 对对对确实
Jake: Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Alice:我是不是得绕一下
Alice: Should I loop around?
Jake: 呃就那边吧
Jake: Uh, just over there.
Jake: 不用绕
Jake: No need to go around
Jake: fa
Jake: 谢谢哎呀哎呦
Jake: Thanks, oh gosh, ouch
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful
Jake: 好疼
Jake: It hurts
Alice:还空出来一个位
Alice: There's still a spot left
Alice:要不然搁前边吧
Alice: How about we put it in the front?
Katrina:  放放我身上也行
Katrina: Putting it on me is fine too
Katrina:  这后面只有两个人
Katrina: There are only two people in the back
Jake: 就放那边吧放那边可以吧
Jake: Just put it over there, that's fine
Jake: 还是放哎呦
Jake: Still put it... ouch
Jake: 好疼好疼啊
Jake: It really hurts
Jake: 摸摸头
Jake: Rub my head
Jake: 哎不用不用不用
Jake: Oh no, no need
Jake: 它自动的它自动的它自动的自动的
Jake: It's automatic, it's automatic, it's automatic
Jake: 摁了他就以为我们要干什么
Jake: If you press it, he will think we are up to something
Alice:我们俩坐后边吧
Alice: Let's sit in the back
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 啊怎么还订6座呢
Tasha: Why did we book 6 seats?
Jake: 那应该点几座
Jake: How many should we have booked?
Katrina:  那我坐老板位了
Katrina: Then I'll sit in the boss's seat
Lucia: 那我还坐前面吧
Lucia: Then I'll sit in the front
Lucia: 如果没有人晕车的话
Lucia: If no one gets car sick
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake: 好疼
Jake: It hurts
Lucia: 哎这个能往后一点吗
Lucia: Can this go a bit back?
Lucia: 啊不我是说这个
Lucia: Oh no, I mean this
Alice:现在还要录吗
Alice: Are we still recording?
Jake: 这个关了吧不
Jake: Let's turn it off
Jake: 不用录了
Jake: No need to record
Tasha: 呃现在就关了
Tasha: Uh, turn it off now?
Jake: 现在关了
Jake: Turn it off now
Jake: 可以这一段可以
Jake: This part is fine
Jake: 这一段主要没有go Pro
Jake: This part mainly without GoPro
Jake: 你每次go Pro贼麻烦
Jake: Every time the GoPro is so troublesome